[Musique]
Françoise Françoise Françoise
Françoise devant l'arrêt de l'autobus
elle avait l'air d'une petite puce avec
ses nates dans le dos et son def côte
vert d'eau des r d'or dans ses cheveux
et des baleurin dans la mais je n'ai vu
que ses B et je l'ai surnommé Françoise
Françoise Françoise B bleu mon bouquet
d'Azure de jeuner des grèves François au
pas bleu petit ange purure descendit des
cieux c'est cahiller au bout d'une
ficelle maintenu entre terre et ciel
balancer le rythme optimiste d'un petit
air de tou de l'autre main avec amour
contreur et le seré le tout dernier 45
tours de
Johnny Françoise Françoise François
frise bleu mon bouquet d'Azur de jeun
François bleu petit an pur descend les
yeux à l'intérieur de l'autobus
j'interrogé la petite bus le résultat de
mon Gal elle n'avait pas de pickup ah
jamais je n'ai mieux je crois que jeis
eu un trait de génie en faisant
installer chez moi la
stéréophonie François au Bas Bleu mon
bouquet d'AZ
de geler des grèves Françoise au pas
bleu petit ange pur descendu des cux
Françoise
Françoise elle a fait l'école
buissonnière la
garonnière tré sans jamais
sarrêter tis que johnyam s gosillé sur
mon à 6h très exactement elle a pris son
métro
Françoise ble d'Azur de jeun des grèves
Françoise au Bas Bleu petit ange pur
descendu des cieux Françoise au faable
petit an pur descend dans les cieux
Françoise au faableu petit ange pur
descend des cieux oh c'est fini
là